c'est une fermeture qui laisse un goût
amer
l'activité économique de la ville de
tours y était rythmée par cette sucrerie
de puissants 40 50 en 2012 sept l'usiné
rachetée par le groupe cristal union qui
possède aujourd'hui 10 sucreries à
travers le pays
une acquisition qui semblait bénéfique
mais qui n'a pas tenu ses promesses
on nous a répondu ce qu'on répond à tout
le monde à la fin des quotas sucriers la
chute des prix du sucre il faut sauver
le groupe
en fermant des usines c'est la vie d'une
commune c'est l'avis de c'est l'avis de
beaucoup de familles qui s'écroule
c'est dur mais c'est aussi une fierté
parce que voilà être qualifié de travail
est indispensable c'est aussi une fierté
il ya encore quelques semaines
on nous jeter à la poubelle aujourd'hui
on nous dit qu'on est indispensable donc
c'est un petit peu paradoxal sur les 128
salariés
près de la moitié ont déjà été licenciés
en février dernier mais depuis le début
de la pandémie
lusine n'a pas chômé elle produit plus
de mille hectolitres d'alcool par jour
matière première indispensable à la
confection de gel hydroalcoolique
rien n'y fait la production de cette
sucrerie doit s'arrêter à la fin du mois
avec une fermeture définitive en octobre
prochain
de quoi déclencher l'incompréhension et
l'inquiétude des élus locaux on nous
avait dit que nous arrivions un gros
groupe sérieux qu'il y avait des
capacités financières à pouvoir passer
l'une de trois mauvaises années bon
certes on s'aperçoit que c'est pas le
message maintenant est tout autre je
crois que dans la tête des gens pendant
encore au moins quelques générations
il y aura toujours l'impact de la
sucrerie qui dira que tour il y avait
une sucrerie il ya une sucrerie et puis
je vous dit deux générations de gens on
travaille à la sucrerie fatalement il y
aura il faudra faire des économies
j'ai bien peur que ce soit
l'investissement communal qui en
subissent quelques conséquences
nos équipes ont tenté de joindre la
direction qui n'a pas donné suite pour
le moment toute l'activité de la ville
s'organise encore autour de la sucrerie
pourtant les habitants de toury n'ont
obtenu aucune réponse concernant
l'avenir de l'usiné